a convicted murderer has a new chance at
freedom after serving nearly a decade in
prison David temple was a hometown
football star and coach in Texas he was
convicted in 2007 for the murder of his
pregnant wife two leading Texas
attorneys clashed over the case but a
new twist has emerged 18 years after the
crime in a preview of tomorrow's 48
hours Richard Schlesinger updates the
story we first brought you last year
guilty of murder as charged named David
temple was convicted of the 1999 murder
of his pregnant wife Belinda he spent
nine years in prison for the crime
prosecutor Kelly Sigler legendary for
her dramatic courtroom tactics tried the
case in 2007 so who is David temple
he's a man who nobody ever said no to
her theory was that temple killed his
wife to be with the woman he was having
an affair with Heather Scott you better
believe he was serious about Heather and
you better believe he was done with
Belinda in his mind temples attorney
dicta Garin like that famous for helping
billionaire Robert Durst get acquitted
of murder reminded jurors that in this
case there was no hard evidence linking
temple to the crime it's true that David
had an affair that doesn't make him a
murderer
temple has always maintained his
innocence and I pray every day and that
my name will from once and all be
cleared in 2012 temple's appellate
attorneys casey Gautreaux and stanley
schneider finally saw the complete
police report and they say it contained
critical evidence never seen before by
the defense on my left is the complete
investigative report this was never seen
this is what was suppressed self was
hidden who hid Sigler hit it sigler hit
it and she hit it well did you turn over
to the 14 hundred pages of police
reports no every single thing
the law mr. de Garin was entitled to was
turned over to him in a split decision
the Texas Court of Criminal Appeals
found temple did not get a fair trial
and he was released in late December
JB's give me and then you saw your
family and then I say my family it's
incredible to just have that touch and
the affection that you've wanted all
that time and I've been able to have
is a sweet sweet joy but it is not over
yet
now a new da must decide whether to drop
the charges or prosecute David temple
all over again Richard Schlesinger is
with us now Richard good morning morning
so are there other alternative suspects
well the defense certainly thinks so
there's some neighborhood kids who mrs.
temple allegedly had some unpleasant
interaction with and they think that
that they might be perfectly good
suspects and that the case turned on how
much evidence was against them versus
how much against David temple and so
this charged that the that the
prosecution withheld some evidence was
very serious for the defense how long is
it for the DA to make a decision here do
you think it'll tell this is another
twist in this thing is it there was a
new DA who took office in January the
police file on this case Anthony is
1,300 some of almost 1400 pages long so
she's got she's promised to personally
review this case she's got a lot of work
ahead of her so we don't know a couple
of months at least lessen your thanks
you can see Richards full report the
alternate suspects tomorrow night at
10:00 9:00 central right here on CBS